okay I'm congresswoman carolyn Maloney
and I represent the 12th congressional
district in New York City and before I
take your questions I I would just like
to thank first and foremost the
incredible New York City Fire Department
they were there within a minute with
over 100 people they put out the fire
they saved the lives also the EMS the
police everyone responded quickly and
safely to it really truly deeply
believed and I call for it before I call
for it for years to ban non-essential
helicopter flight over New York City I
can see why people need to sin a fire
but to walk around with it anyway it's
just it's a it's becoming a little
ridiculous there's also a quality of
life issue
I have constituents calling me when when
they're flying near their homes or the
noise or right outside my windows a
helicopter why is that allowed we can
get on a personal note but also for the
men and women that deserve it they've
had our backs we've got to have their
backs and I want to thank my office for
putting this together and and we will
start the negotiations with the FAA we
will call